kanye west has seemingly grounded
himself
and he's not coming out until he
finishes donda
i mean it was just fun to go in and just
do something for my heart
according to multiple reports the rapper
is living at atlanta's mercedes-benz
stadium as he continues to work on his
new album
donda named after kanye's late mother
was supposed to be released at midnight
on friday
following his listening event at the
venue thursday night
it's extremely important to me well that
release date
came and went and still no album
and according to variety kanye is now
eying to drop his new music
on august 6th e.t has reached out to
kanye's rep
for comment but on saturday people
started wondering about the grammy
winners living situation
when he was spotted at an atlanta united
fc
soccer game in the stadium the dada4 was
wearing the same outfit he sported
during his thursday
listening party
[Music]
during that listening event on thursday
kanye played his new album for guests
including his estranged wife kim
kardashian
and their four kids eight-year-old north
five-year-old saint
three-year-old chicago and two-year-old
[Music]
psalm
it was an emotional night kanye dropping
to his knees during
this track love unconditionally five
months after kim filed for divorce
[Music]
kim and kanye's split was also heavily
covered on keeping up with the
kardashians 20th and final season
earlier this year
i feel like a failure that it's like a
third marriage
yeah i feel like a loser back in 2018
kim opened up to e.t about kanye's
creative process
after he dropped his album yay does he
come to you before and say lick wifey
i'm gonna put this song out and get your
approval beforehand do you guys do that
yet yes it's a
really fascinating process especially
since he like scrapped his whole album
and redid it
in the last two weeks and just came up
with all new songs so that was really
interesting i left to go home for like
two days and then i come back and it was
a whole new album
kim filed for divorce back in february
after six years of marriage
and at the time a source told e.t quote
at the end of the day kanye and kim love
each other immensely but knew it was
time to call it quits
their children are their number one
priority and no matter what will
maintain a positive relationship for
them